量子もつれは、粒子間の距離に関係なく粒子を結びつけることができる――これは非常に直感に反する話だ
Einsteinでさえ本当だとは思っていなかったほどだ。今日の「教室でのkissk」では、Bellの
定理がEinsteinの
誤りを証明した話をする。「教室でのkuit」へようこそ。このシリーズでは、kkitを使って量子コンピューティング関連の講義で
よく取り上げられる基本的な概念を探っていく。各動画には、インタラクティブなモジュールも付属している
説明欄にリンクがあるので、ぜひ確認してほしい。「量子コイン」の動画では、量子の重ね合わせを測定することが、
ある意味でコインを投げるのと似た、本質的に確率的なプロセスであることを説明した。でも、それをどうやって確かめるんだろう
量子粒子が測定結果をあらかじめ秘密裏に決めているのに、それを私たちが
理論の中でうまく捉えられていないだけ、ということはあり得るんだろうか。量子力学の黎明期、この問いは
激しい議論の的だった。大きく二つの陣営に分かれていて、一方にはEinsteinがいた。彼は量子力学は不完全だと考えていた
つまり、系を完全に記述するために必要な変数が欠けているというわけだ。Einsteinは、
これらのいわゆる隠れた変数が見つかれば、量子力学の一見逆説的で確率的な
側面が解消されると考えていた。もう一方の陣営にはMax Bornがいた。Bornが主張したのは、
量子力学が与える確率的な記述こそが、自然が規定するすべてだということだ。つまり、
測定前に粒子の状態を知らないというだけでなく、測定前には粒子に確定した状態がそもそも存在しない
というわけだ。何十年もの間、多くの人はこの対立を、決して解決されないかもしれない哲学的な問いだと考えていた
結局、系について何かを知るには測定が必要だ。測定前の状態の性質について、どうやって知ることができるだろう。
そして1964年、物理学者の
John Bellが突破口を見つけた。論文の中でBellは、一対の
もつれた粒子の測定間の統計的相関を調べた。もし測定前に粒子の状態が何らかの未知の隠れた変数によって決まっているなら、
Bellはその相関に上限があることを示した。一方、量子力学が予測する
相関を計算したところ、その上限を超えることがわかった。こうして彼は、EinsteinとBornの見解を
決定的に区別する方法を見つけた。あとは実際に実験で
本物の粒子を使ってその相関を検証し、隠れた変数の統計に従うか、それとも
その規則に反するかを確かめるだけだった。これらの検証は年々精度と洗練度を増しながら行われ、
現代物理学において最も重要な実験の一つとなった。あまりに画期的だったため、
2022年に三人の物理学者がノーベル賞を受賞した。でも今では、誰でも
Bell検定を実行できる。必要なのは、kcitの基礎知識とIBMの量子コンピュータへのアクセスだけだ。この動画では、
Bellの不等式の論理を順を追って説明し、IBMの
量子コンピュータでBellの予測を検証する方法を紹介する。Bellの不等式にはいくつかの異なる測定と論理の層が含まれていて、
少し追いにくいかもしれないが、一歩一歩進めていこう。最後にはきっとその価値がわかるはずだ。これから
もつれが実在し、Einsteinが間違っていることを示そうとしている。それをやってのけたと言える人はそう多くないから。では、
Bellが提案したことを説明しよう。多数のもつれた粒子ペアを生成する手段があるとしよう。
物理的には、一つの粒子が二つに崩壊する崩壊過程でこれらのペアを生成できる。「Stern-Gerlach実験」の動画を見たことがあれば、
粒子にはスピンと呼ばれる固有の角運動量があることを知っているはずだ。
スピンゼロの粒子がスピン1/2の
二つの粒子に崩壊するとしよう。すると各スピン1/2の粒子は、スピン+1/2またはマイナス
1/2、つまりスピンアップまたはスピンダウンとして測定される。ただし、スピンゼロの粒子から崩壊したのだから、二つを合わせると
合計スピンがゼロにならなければならない。つまり、一方がアップと測定されれば、もう一方は必ず
ダウンになり、その逆も同じだ。これらの粒子は、こんなふうなもつれたペアを形成する
つまり、一方がアップと測定されれば、もう一方はダウンで、その逆も然りだ。粒子1は左、つまり
マイナスX方向に飛んでいき、そこでLucasと呼ぶ研究者がそのスピンを測定する
するとします。粒子2は同様に右方向に飛んでいき、
もう一人の研究者Rihannnaがそのスピンを測定できる。LucasとRihannaは独立して
測定装置を回転させ、各自の粒子のスピンを粒子の進行方向に垂直な任意の方向に沿って測定することを選べる
LucasとRihannaにもつれ状態のコピーを多数送れば、
二人は測定の統計を収集できる。常に同じ軸で測定すると、この統計はあまり
面白くない。一方がスピンアップを測定するたびに、もう一方はスピンダウンを測定し、一方がスピン
フォワードを測定するたびに、もう一方はスピンバックワードを測定する、といった具合だ。でも二人が異なる軸で測定すると、
もっと興味深いことが見えてくるかもしれない。LucasとRihannaに三つの軸を与えよう。
これらの軸をa、b、cと呼ぶことにする。それぞれ
120°ずつ離れている。この実験で問うのは、LucasとRihannaが三つの軸のうち任意の一つで自由に測定できるとき、
二人が同じ符号を得る頻度はどれくらいか、ということだ。明らかに、LucasとRihannaがたまたま同じ軸、
例えば軸aで測定した場合、粒子のスピンの合計がゼロでなければならないので、同じ符号になることはあり得ない。でも、異なる軸を選んだ場合、
二人の測定はどのように相関しているんだろう。Einsteinによれば、粒子の状態に関するこの量子
力学的な記述は不完全だ。彼は、隠れた変数が存在して
すべての可能なスピン測定の結果をあらかじめ決めているはずだと考えていた。そうでなければ、もつれた粒子同士が
測定の結果を瞬時にお互いに伝え合わなければならなくなる。一方がはるか遠くでアップと測定されたなら、
もう一方は瞬時にダウンだと知らなければならないことになる。
これらの隠れた変数は、実験の結果に対する複雑な指示のセットであり得る。でも重要なのは、
各粒子のスピン状態が個別に決定されているということだ。だから通信は不要になる
実験的には、Lucasが行った測定はRihannaの粒子に影響を与えず、その逆も同様だということになる
これは、二つの測定がどれほど相関できるかに制限を設けるかもしれない。しかしBornによれば、この状態
サイは、測定前の粒子ペアについて言えることの全てだ。だから一方の粒子の測定が
もう一方の測定結果に影響を与える。これは測定間の相関について異なる含意を持つかもしれない。それぞれが
理論にどう影響するか、隠れた変数の扱いで相関を見てみよう。測定前に
Lucasが三つの軸それぞれに沿って何を測定するかをすでに決定する、秘密の指示のセットがある。例えば
指示は、Lucasが軸aに沿って測定すれば正になりうる
bに沿って測定すれば正、cに沿って測定すれば負になる。これを
プラスa、プラスb、マイナスcと書ける。するとRihannaの粒子は
マイナスa、マイナスb、プラスcという変数を持つ必要がある。どの単一方向に沿ったスピンの合計も
ゼロになるように
このスピンゼロの制約を満たす指示のセットは8通りある。だから新しいペアの
粒子がLucasとRihannaに送られるたびに、この8通りの指示セットのうちいずれかを含みうる。では
粒子が表にある秘密の指示セットのうち一つを含むと仮定して、かつ
LucasとRihannaがそれぞれ独立に三つの軸のうちどれに沿って測定するかを選ぶとして、
二人が同じ符号を測定する確率はどれくらいか。指示が行1または
8のものであれば、この確率は明らかにゼロだ。なぜなら二つの粒子は測定軸に関係なく逆の符号を持つから
しかし行2の指示についてはどうか。RihannaがcでLucasがaかbのどちらかを測定した場合、または
Lucasがcを測定してRihannaがAかBのどちらかを測定した場合、同じ符号を測定する。それは9通りのうち4通りの
可能な測定の組み合わせで、LucasとRihannaに同じ符号が得られる。これを
各指示セットについて行うと、行3から7も9分の4の確率を与えることがわかる。つまり
Einsteinが正しく、こうした隠れた変数が測定結果を事前に決めるなら、Lucasと
Rihannaが9分の4より大きい確率で同じ符号を測定することは絶対にない。これがベル不等式、P未満
または等しい9分の4だ。そして示すように、もつれた粒子はこれに違反する。では
量子力学が何を予測するかを見てみよう。Lucasがaに沿って測定するとすると、二つのことが起こりうる。スピンアップを測定するか、
つまりRihannaはaに沿ってスピンダウンを測定するか、またはスピンダウンを測定してRihannaはaに沿ってスピンアップを測定する。しかし
aだけでなく、Rihannaが自分で選んだどの軸に沿っても、Lucasと同じ符号を測定する確率が知りたい
もし彼女がbかcのどちらかに沿って測定するなら、少し複雑になる。実は
ある方向に沿って100%の確実性でRihannaが測定することが何かわかっているなら、
他のどの軸に沿ってもアップまたはダウンを測定する確率を少しの幾何学で計算できる
ある軸に沿って常にスピンアップを測定する状態なら、別の軸に沿ってスピンアップを測定する確率は
二つの軸の間の角度の1/2のコサインの二乗に等しい。少し複雑だが
どういう意味か示そう。Lucasがaに沿ってスピンアップを測定したなら、RihannaがaにSピンダウンを測定することが100%確実にわかる
だからそれをベクトルVORで表すことができる
こんな感じに。この場合、このベクトルと他の二つの測定軸BとCの角度はどちらも
60度なので、その半分は30度だ。そして
コサイン30はここに示す。コサインの二乗
30度は4分の3に等しい。もしLucasがaに沿ってスピンダウンを測定したなら
RihannaはaにSピンアップを測定するとわかる。だからここに別のベクトルを描ける。さて
この知識を表すベクトルは、他の二つの軸BとCのそれぞれから120度の位置にある
だから同じ幾何学のトリックができるが、今回はコサイン
60度を使う。コサインの二乗
60度は1/4に等しい。Lucasはaに沿ってスピンアップとスピンダウンを測定する可能性が等しいので、
RihannaのこれらニつのS率を平均する必要がある。最終的に
Rihannaがlucasと同じ符号を測定する確率は12分の1という結果になる。だからP
イコール2分の1は9分の4より大きい。つまりベル不等式は違反されている
それは量子力学の法則が成立する限り、隠れた変数は不可能だということを意味する。今、Qiskitと
IBMの量子コンピュータを使って、実際の量子測定でベル不等式をテストできる。スピンアップと
LucasとRihannaの粒子のスピンダウン状態を、量子コンピュータのqubitのゼロと一の状態にマッピングできる
二つのqubitを取り、一つはLucasの粒子を表し、もう一つはRihannaのを表し、この量子circuit でもつれさせる
二つのqubitは二つのワイヤq0とq1で表される。このXとHadamardとCNOT gateの組み合わせが
LucasとRihannaの粒子の間にあったのと同じもつれた状態を作る。さて
各qubitを測定する必要がある。Lucasの測定をaに沿って、Z軸とするよう設定する。するとRihannaの
測定はa、b、cのどれかに沿うことができるので、この三つのケースそれぞれに対して三つの別々のcircuitが必要だ。しかしこの
動画では一つだけやる。全部については説明欄のモジュールリンクを見てほしい。RihannaがBに沿って測定するなら
circuit はこうなる。ryは測定軸を変えるための120度の回転で
RihannaのS定軸を変える。Qiskitのプリミティブsamplerを使って、この実験を何度も実行して
結果の測定から統計を集めることができる。00と11の二つの列は、LucasとRihannaが
同じ符号を測定した時を表しており、それが欲しいものだ。だから両方の粒子が
同じ符号を持つと測定される確率はほぼ1/2だ。これはベル不等式に違反している。つまり
二つの粒子はもつれており、どちらかが瞬時にもう一方の測定結果を知るようだ
このもつれをどう解釈するか、またもつれた状態を測定するときに何が起きるかについては
まだ意見の相違がある。しかしこれらの問いはより哲学的なもので、
理論はこの時点ではかなり否定しがたい。もつれは間違いなく実在する。これはBellのおかげでわかっている。彼の
不等式と、それをテストする実験を行った多くの物理学者のおかげで。それらの物理学者の一員として数えられ、
量子コンピュータで自分自身のBellテストを行いたいなら、説明欄にリンクされたベル不等式モジュールに
ぜひアクセスしてほしい。見てくれてありがとう。また次回